hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Argentinian crime Thriller
film called the Heist of the century
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
Fernando araujo lives a decent life as
an artist and a judo instructor however
he's not satisfied and thinks that he's
still on the lookout for his calling one
night on his way back home he stops for
a smoke as it rains heavily after
Fernando is done he discards the
cigarette which slowly drifts away and
falls into a sewer near the bank of Rio
curious he goes down the sewer and
suddenly a crazy idea crosses his mind
the following day Fernando goes to meet
his civil engineer friend Sebastian and
proposes the idea of robbing the bank it
turns out Sebastian is financially
struggling so he's open to the idea but
he estimates that the plan would require
cars tools and lots of money therefore
Fernando starts looking for a funder and
meets his other friend named debauza
unfortunately the latter is also short
on money so he suggests Fernando go to
his Thief friend Mario since when is
Mario friends with dabasa oh God the
scene then cuts to Mario who breaks into
an office at night and immaculately
steals money from a safe he doesn't even
appear worried throughout the ordeal
indicating that minor robberies like
these are a piece of cake for him the
next day Fernando meets Mario at a cafe
and explains his idea the master Thief
is initially disinterested but Fernando
convinces him by saying that if they
pull off the heist he would never have
to steal again Fernando then drives him
to the same location and lowers a
measuring tape inside the manhole right
outside the bank he also takes Mario
down to the sewers to find the bottom of
the tape after some calculation Fernando
announces that they are 18 meters away
from becoming millionaires in the next
scene Fernando Mario and de bausa
gathered to discuss the heist further
they plan to dig a tunnel into the bank
but all of the rooms inside have motion
sensors however Fernandez says that
motions don't detect movements they only
identify changes in temperature
therefore he has made a suit out of a
sleeping bag which can help them
disguise their body temperature now out
the only problem is that he doesn't know
how to open the bank vault so the
following day the group decides to
investigate some more Fernando takes
pictures of the bank's parking lot
situated behind the building before
going inside with Sebastian the latter
pretends to open an account while
Fernando takes pictures of the foyer
unfortunately he is soon caught and the
security arrives Fernando quickly tries
to leave but the security apprehends him
and escorts him to the basement for
questioning surprisingly this was all
part of the plan Fernando uses this
opportunity to closely observe the safe
deposit box room meanwhile the security
check all of his belongings including
the camera but they do not find any
evidence and reluctantly let him go it's
then revealed that Fernando had managed
to remove the memory card of the camera
but for some reason security didn't find
that suspicious at all later Fernando
and Sebastian dropped the bank's floor
plan using the pictures and their memory
Fernando then hatches a plan to break
into the bank from the small room next
they measure the distance between the
manhole and the bank using a by bicycle
by calculating the number of times the
tire rotates the next day Fernando uses
his knowledge of geometry to calculate
the angle at which they must dig up the
tunnel to reach the bank it's also
revealed that the money the group is set
to steal is insured so no one except the
bank will have to incur a loss because
of them later that night Fernando and
the others go into the sewer and start
digging up the tunnel the following day
they hire another guy named Alberto who
is set to take care of the getaway car
Fernando and the group are yet to find a
way to open 400 lockers they initially
consider using a blowtorch but it would
take them one and a half minutes per box
and seven hours in total therefore
Fernando suggests renting a locker and
studying it closely but from another
branch of the bank the following day
Mario goes to another branch of the same
bank and rents a safety deposit box
while opening it he closely watches the
lock next Mario and his accomplice steal
a getaway van and wait for Alberto
outside his Helm shortly after they are
approached by police the duo panics
thinking that their going to be caught
but fortunately Alberto and his wife
arrive and tell the officer that they
are friends the group continues digging
the tunnel and one day they meet with an
accident and break the drill Fernando
brushes the incident aside and plans to
buy a new drill but this infuriates
Mario as he has already invested a lot
of money in the project later that night
Fernando visits his girlfriend and they
gaze at the stars together they talk
about how they are looking at the past
of the stars as the light takes years to
reach Earth we think they exist but
they're gone this suddenly gives
Fernando an idea and he immediately
heads to Mario's home Fernando tells him
that he has found the solution he says
that the bank is well protected when it
is both open and closed but the measures
are different the bank has good security
measures to prevent cash theft and good
protocols to avoid the tunnel Heist
however they don't have a measure to
prevent them both from happening at the
same time Fernando plans to enter the
bank from the front during work hours
when the safety vault is open thus
avoiding alarm and motion sensors this
will give of the cops an impression that
they are small-time thieves who are
after petty cash Fernando wants to make
everyone believe that they are planning
to leave from the front door so that the
cops won't even suspect a tunnel Escape
hearing all this Mario is delighted and
he absolutely loves the idea you got all
that from looking at the stars man
the scene then cuts to the day of the
heist everyone applies glue to their
fingers to hide their fingerprints
Sebastian is dropped by the sewer and he
goes inside to do his work while
Fernando and the others enter the bank
in a disguise before putting on their
masks shortly after Mario and de bausa
head to the first floor while Fernando
and Alberto take over the ground floor
at the same time they pull out their
weapons and Order everyone to lay on the
ground a security guard watches it
transpire from the CCTV room and
immediately alerts the police it's then
revealed that Fernando is overhearing
the communication from his walkie-talkie
Mario orders the cashier to load the
money into a bag while Alberto goes to
lock the parking gate the police
eventually arrive outside and seeing
this Fernando holds a civilian at
gunpoint he then threatens to kill the
man if the police try to storm into the
bank following this Fernando returns
inside and informs his accomplices that
the first phase has been completed as
soon as Mario hears this he holds a
woman at gunpoint and orders the
security guard in the CCTV room to
surrender himself the guard reluctantly
obliges and Mario seizes his Guns
Magazine and mobile phone before
releasing him outside next the group
disables all the cameras in the bank
Fernando goes to the small room and
moves a cabinet from the other side
Sebastian breaks the wall and enters the
bank through the tunnel the two then
fetch some equipment from their car head
to the Vault and start assembling the
machine the flashback then reveals that
Sebastian had built a Canon Power
machine which can break the lock within
seven seconds next everyone sets a timer
on their watches as Sebastian and
Fernando start to break into all the
lockers meanwhile the police media and
the relatives of the hostages gather
outside the bank the police captain
speaks to the security guard and gets to
know about the situation inside
elsewhere as Fernando and Sebastian
continue to break open the lockers
suddenly they hear the police climbing
on the roof Mario then gets the
captain's call on the guard's phone
which he had taken earlier a flashback
reveals that Fernando had also prepared
for this scenario so he made Mario
practice the art of negotiation don't do
it let me go oh back in the present
Mario speaks to the captain I'm gonna
negotiate and orders him to remove all
the forces from the Terrace threatening
to kill the civilians I'll do it the
captain obliges but he covertly sends
two snipers on the neighboring building
he then asks Mario about his demands and
the latter tells him that he wants to
speak to the district attorney the
captain agrees to fulfill his demand and
requests one hour of time from him
meanwhile Fernando and Sebastian have
already unlocked a lot of lockers
recovering tons of cash gold and other
precious ornaments outside the police
assessed the situation there are only
two ways to enter the bank from the main
gate and the parking lot however they do
not know anything about the location of
the hostages they also conclude that it
is simply an attempted robbery after a
while the captain again gets on a call
with Mario and asks him to surrender he
says that the burglars haven't heard
anyone yet so they will get away with a
light sentence the captain also offers
to find him a lawyer in response Mario
says that he will discuss it with his
accomplices all this while Fernando and
Sebastian should break into more lockers
while the police wait outside helplessly
just then an old hostage's phone starts
to ring and it's revealed that it's her
birthday today happy birthday but shut
up or I'll kill you Mario then wishes
her a happy birthday while the Bowser
takes a chocolate from another hostage
and gives it to her the snipers watch
them celebrate the woman's birthday and
relay the information back to the
captain surprising him meanwhile Mario
sets the woman free as a birthday
present and because her name was Peach
he then leans against a window and tells
the captain that he has spent 15 years
in prison and that he will only
surrender if the D.A assures him that he
will get a light sentence upon hearing
this the captain orders the sniper to
hold back and Mario gets away from the
window it's then revealed that he was
actually testing if the police would
shoot him soon the D.A arrives and
speaks with Mario surprisingly the
latter starts hurling abuses at the D.A
and refuses to talk with him Mario then
demands to speak with his lawyer instead
however when the captain asks for the
lawyer's number Mario gives him the
phone number of a hostage he then
changes his phone and speaks to the D.A
as his fake lawyer in this way he buys
his burglar friends some more time next
Mario holds up all the hostages on the
first floor while Fernando and others
finally start transporting their loot
through the tunnel Mario then switches
off his mobile phone and this makes the
captain doubt if he is really serious
about surrendering just then he notices
the manhole and figures out that the
burglars have found an alternate way to
escape meanwhile after loading the loot
on the boats Fernando leaves all the
weapons in the vault for the police a
flashback then reveals that all the
weapons are actually children's toys
because Fernando didn't want to hurt any
civilians finally Mario leaves the
hostages on the first floor and joins
Fernando in the small room as soon as he
does so all the scared hostages pick up
their phones and call their relatives
outside the captain also sends a troop
into the sewer while another one storms
into the bank from the front Fernando
and Mario quickly clear all the evidence
of the tunnel and join the others in the
boat another flashback reveals that
Fernando had also anticipated the police
finding out about the sewer therefore
they had already built a dam to increase
the water level which would allow them
to go in the opposite direction on a
motorboat what elsewhere the captain
reaches the small room and eventually
the tunnel opening where a bomb is
blocking the entrance however he soon
learns that the bomb along with the
weapons is fake unfortunately for the
captain it's too late as the thieves
have already managed to escape meanwhile
Fernando and the group flee the scene in
their getaway vehicle and destroy all
their gears they then head to Alberto's
house and divide the loot equally
amongst themselves several months have
now passed and the group appears to be
enjoying their best lives however one
day Alberto's wife catches him cheating
on her this infuriates her so much that
she reports him to the police exposing
him as one of the thieves in the bank
heist hell half mil Fury man as a result
one by one all of the thieves are
arrested Alberto doesn't know how to
keep it zipped the movie again fast
forward seven months into the future
Fernando is released from the present
and he is welcomed by Mario in his
luxury car it's then revealed that
Fernando had also prepared for a
scenario in which they got caught he
purposely suggested that they use toy
weapons so that they don't hurt anyone
and get away with lighter sentences
Fernando and others also get to keep a
significant portion of their loot
because the bank doesn't keep records of
the money and items kept in the safety
deposit boxes the bank estimated that
the lockers stored 25 million worth of
cash and jewelry but the police only
recovered 1.17 million and 8 kilograms
of jewelry since there was no official
record of the items in the lockers the
police couldn't pursue a strong case
against the criminals and they basically
got away with only a slap on the wrist
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching